vince casey congratulations you guys
have made it into the third round of
this competition
now it's not going to get any easier as
we send you home to recreate
this iconic weapon from history
good luck gents we'll see you in four
days
it's day one i'm here in mount airy
maryland getting ready to
build the jian sword here we go
i guess that quick i've decided to use
adcrv2
it's going to give it additional
toughness more springiness
start at the tip and work my way back i
have never made
anything as long as a giant sword so
this is
completely new territory well that's not
good
so i got a bend as i forge a blade
i keep having this little ghost visiting
and
kinking the blade i'm gonna get it
straightened
not quite
[Music]
all right so i think i'm okay today
was pretty good actually got laid more
or less profiled
and so far it looks pretty good i need a
shower a cold deer would not hurt
[Music]
so it's day one i'm back in oklahoma i'm
ready
to get started on this giant sword i'm
gonna go prep my steel
i'm gonna try to spice it up a bit with
a little damascus
i'm doing 1084 and 15 and 20.
i figured that would look cool low layer
with a twist
whoa that's good we've got this thing
drawn out and as you twist it it cools
it even faster and the more it cools
down the harder it's twist
so you don't want to fight it when it
tells you to stop you want to stop i
don't want to risk it
the vegas too cold you can induce stress
fractures
i'm looking good got that twist in there
and now i've got to square back up and
draw it out
looking good i think today's day two
got a good night's sleep hopefully i get
to quench by the end of the day
trying to get the bevels established
[Music]
i think that's pretty good so i finished
all my bevels and
i'm ready to quench i'm trying to hurry
up in here
we have thunderstorms coming with the
rain
it can cause all the oil to splatter out
and i will pin that burn
so i really need to get this done
so i get the blade to temperature and i
pull the blade out
and it's got a slight warp trying to
correct it while the blade is still hot
ends up fire but we got a straight blade
i feel excited yes and i know
i have a good chance of winning this
thing
perfect timing
so it's the beginning of day three got
the guard on i've got the handle where i
want it
i got to get this pommel on there so i'm
going to grab this tang down
i've got the pretty thick tail end of
this tank here and i'm trying
to thread it oh it doesn't
this threat is just not working oh
that's disappointing
so i go back to the grinder and grind it
down to the next size
threader it's
too thin so i've got this dinky threaded
tang here
cut that tang right off this might cost
me 10 grand
now that there's nothing left to thread
i've got to fit a bolt into this
position here goes the welding
all right we'll see how that works
today's day four and we're going to put
the last few things together
so right now i'm just too black and this
i chose to do it on black
for the guard pretty happy with it and
then i'm on to
polishing and sharpening the blade
really have to be careful now because
this
is sharp so i put the whole thing
together and i noticed that it's a
little too big
we are just over three pounds i'm
shooting for
under three pounds total weight i start
shrinking my pommel i know i have too
much metal
uh it's too heavy too big that reduced
about a quarter of its weight
and now i just got to put it together it
goes nothing
[Music]
now that everything is together it's
finally done
[Music]
it's day four and i'm ready to start
getting this sword together
it's looking like a sword man i'm gonna
finalize the edge
haven't done really any double-edged
swords actually so a little bit
challenging because now you got two
blades that could catch you so
i'm taking it nice and slow real calm
and collected
the sacrifices we make for our art so
once i get everything assembled
i'm going to take this thing out here
and swing it around see what i can cut
up with it
[Music]
two pounds ten ounces of kill you quick
giant sword all right bladesmiths
welcome
to kill test now
your giant swords look beautiful but are
they deadly well to find that out i will
take your weapon and do some slashes and
thrust on this ballistic tummy
vincero first you ready give her hell
i always wanted to hear doug said it
will kill
so the anticipation is just killing me i
want to see him
get through the test and see what he
does
all right vince let's talk about your
jian sword up here
overall i like the aesthetics
of this sword now your handle
construction
is within scale of this blade it's
comfortable when i wrap around it
now your edge is razor sharp
in thrusting it cuts out and when you
swing you can feel the impact of this
sword
overall sir it'll kill
wanted to hear that good job hey casey
you got the stomach for this you're next
i'm ready
forging fire makes you nervous excited
scared
and happy all the same time i'm very
confident my blade
it's just you never know i've seen
blades break i don't want that to happen
to mine
[Music]
all right casey let's talk about your
giant sword here
first up i like the lines that you have
with your sword here
and the damascus pattern i can
appreciate that
and now in cutting it was so much fun
just to be able to slice
over and over and over
with ease with a blade that moves
this sir will kill thank you
[Music]
bladesmiths welcome to the strength
tests
[Music]
now to test the edge holding ability of
your blades and the overall strength and
construction
i'm going to take each of your swords
and smash them
repeatedly into these heavy pots now
i'm not really concerned what your
blades do to the pots even though it's
going to look really cool and be a lot
of fun
i want to see what the pots are going to
your blades and edges
vince you're up first you ready to go
yes sir jay picks up my blade and he
looks excited he's just looking forward
to smashing it
but at the same time if he survives jay
i know it'll survive
anything
i hope vents i tell you it's a great
blade i mean where i was striking is
still sharp
still straight and true but the problem
is
doing your pommel your threads here
didn't go very far through so pummel
broke loose
bit of a problem
vince your blade has suffered a
catastrophic failure after three shots
on the pots
a pummel is critical to a one-handed
weapons retention
but that doesn't mean that this
competition is over casey
these are some pretty strong terra cotta
pots and
you'll have to survive three pot shots
to make it out of here
i'll feel ready all right jay you ready
[Music]
if the pots can knock off a pommel they
could do anything
it all comes down to this got a little
bit of knots in my stomach let's see
what happens
[Music]
looks good
casey congratulations your blade
survived vince
unfortunately you cannot continue
testing please
exit the forge i'm disappointed i think
i made a hell of a blade
it was still sharp after the three
terracottas
but the blade needs to be a hundred
percent
mine was 98 and it failed
congratulations good job brother thank
you for the hell of a fight
this is bringing me one step closer to
continue to achieve my dreams
and i wouldn't change a thing
casey congratulations you are the forge
and fire champion and that's the title
that comes with a check
for 10 000 big ones buddy
congratulations
thank you the deed is done
and i won great steal and a great job on
the handle too
i've proven to myself that i can make
a damn good blade for me that's nothing
better
you